[Music]
I think the first time actually I I met
danger Ranger was just randomly out on
the playa in 1996 and and then slightly
less randomly when back when there was
rave camp in camp and we were camped
somewhere in-between and somebody got
hit in their tents and then I remember
going over there and you were out that
way and it was a pretty intense moment
but I kind of had met him in weird
intense moments of flamethrowers and
things like that through the years and
it wasn't until just a few months ago
when I saw him give a version of this
talk for a kind of future of Burning Man
planning session and I was blown away by
both how objective he was and for since
I knew he was kind of in the middle of
all these things he's become an amazing
historian that is able to get a kind of
a thousand foot view on it at the same
time her being intimately connected to
it so I really hope you enjoy tonight
the the note is also that this is a
longer talk than normal we'll probably
won't have too much time for questions
but we'll be hanging out you'll be
hanging out this evening for more
discussion and I think there's actually
a lot of people in this room that have a
lot of great backstory on the on the
things that will be talked about so I
think we can kind of distribute that
need as it goes on so welcome Michael
Michael
thank you
yes the five ages of Burning Man hello
and welcome to the interval I want to
thank the long now foundation for asking
me to speak here tonight I'm going to
talk about the structural history of
Burning Man so prepare yourself for 30
years crammed into 60 minutes for those
of you don't know me let me briefly tell
you about myself in the 1960s the Navy
sent me from Texas to San Francisco
afterwards I went to work in Silicon
Valley as an engineer during the early
days of the personal computer I work for
Fairchild Semiconductor during the 1970s
I once passed up an offer to be involved
with a new company called Intel I never
regretted that decision in the early
1980s I managed the installation of
Apple computers first robotic assembly
line after that I helped start one of
the first technology companies to be
located in San Francisco maybe I should
apologize for that
now I'm social engineer and historian
I've attended Burning Man 29 times and
they call me Danger Danger
this is a story I'm going to tell you
about the five ages of Burning Man this
is story of a cultural movement the
evolution of an organization and the
discovery of Civic design this is also
my story your mileage may vary first you
need to know a little bit about what
happened before a Burning Man came into
being its roots lie in the 1960s and 70s
bohemian culture of San Francisco in San
Francisco in the 1980s I was a member of
a kind of social club called the
cacophony Society each month various
members got together and did events
which were often odd unusual and
challenging cacophony drew from
eccentric European traditions that
preceded us like the dhatus the
surrealist and the Situationist other
local influences were San Cisco culture
jammers like the beats the Merry
Pranksters the diggers and an
underground cacophony precursor called
The Suicide Club we had an open
membership and made sure we were not
underground our motto was a randomly
gathered network of free spirits United
in the pursuit of experiences beyond the
pale of mainstream society you may
already be a member
cacophony devote numerous traditions
that made its events remarkable everyone
was included you had permission to be or
try anything events needed to be free
you took responsibility for your actions
you left places cleaner than when you
found them we use fake names and long
before smartphones it was be here now do
aqua see if you have a great idea you do
it everyone is a participant there were
no spectators political and religious
propaganda was unwelcome which goes back
to including everyone these are some of
the things that could koppány later gave
to Burning Man and so we enter the first
age the age of exploration let's see how
it unfolded 1986 a guy named Larry
Harvey called his friend Jerry James and
said hey let's build a man and burn him
on the beach
Larry Harvey and Jerry James best
friends Larry a dreamer and Jerry a
carpenter built an 8 foot high wooden
figure resembling a man and burn it on
the beach for the summer solstice it's
little more than a family picnic
larry and jerry each brought their young
boys their ex-wives and the roommates
and the boys fashioned a wooden dog to
accompany the man not sure how to make a
fire they doused the figure with
gasoline and light it which goes up like
a second Sun strangers come running from
everywhere down the beach which creates
a party around it very excited by the
response decides to do it again the next
year but bigger of course and so they
did the second time they made more of an
effort to invite people was this flyer
Jerry James the carpenter help Larry
Bill a man that was a little taller
about 15 feet it was a small affair
maybe 20 or 30 people but they had a
tradition on their hands then in 1988 I
heard about some people who were going
to burn a wooden man on Baker Beach on
the Solstice I assume there were pagans
or something but it sounded fun so a
friend and I went down to the beach but
there were no pagans it was Larry Harvey
and Jerry James collaborating on this
very Dada anti art project of creation
and destruction at 30 feet their third
man was twice as tall and more complex
the arms were made to pivot by pulling
on a rope after he stood erect it was
all very interesting after that I kept
in touch with him since I was a
principal editor the cacophony Society
newsletter I decided I would list next
year's event in a future issue of the
newsletter which was perpetually titled
rough draft when the cacophony Society
saw the event listed in our June of 89
newsletter the number of attendees
quadrupled word-of-mouth became the
printed page and cacophony came out in
force and pitched in to help with
logistics communication and
destruction by now the man had become 40
feet tall the height it would remain for
the next two decades it took several
pickup trucks to haul the parts to the
beach participation is high in these
first years with lots of hands to sneak
the parts down to the beach before the
authorities could notice by 1990 we were
showing up on the beach with 350 people
but by then many of these people were
not friends or friends of friends we had
a four-story tall wooden man and more
uninvested spectators as darkness
approached we prepared to erect the man
but this time the authorities arrived
before we could strike a match you can't
do this here where's your permit here
Jerry James and Larry Harvey discussed
the matter while as an apprehensive
crewman crew member looks on after much
negotiation we convinced the authorities
that we would erect the man but not burn
it the crowd many of whom were drunken
has simply come for the spectacle were
not happy amid cries of burn it anyway
Larry realized that the event was not
the same anymore it was too easy to show
up and have an opinion it was now
attracting the wrong people but even
with an angry crowd we kept our word we
had a party around the man but we did
not burn it on the beach that night and
it turned out okay because we heard
about a place far out in Nevada where we
could burn a giant wooden man we were
just going to have to think outside the
San Francisco box and leave the first
age behind so here are the factors we
just looked at which made the first age
what it was a free experimental
underground event with a low barrier to
entry but with a high rate of
participation by experienced cacophony
veterans
now we enter the age of rapid growth
Burning Man moves to the harsh Nevada
desert and develops its full culture and
nearly flies out of control by the end
of this age Nevada is the only place
where Burning Man could have taken root
grown and matured it's a place where
anyone could gamble in fact we roll the
dice
each year in the beginning we burned
through our credit cards we press on
against all odds two months after the
solstice event on the beach was shut
down by the police a new event was
listed in rough draft it was called zone
trip number four bad day at Black Rock
cacophonous John law and Kevin Evans had
been planning an event in the Black Rock
Desert a place outside the reach of
urban rules and regulations and now we
decided to bring Larry's homeless
sculpture with us the Black Rock Desert
two hours North America is a four
hundred square mile dry lakebed the
playa is a barren flat plain devoid of
plants and animals there are no rocks
there
this is liminal space a true tabla rasa
or blank slate upon which you can make a
big mark we heard about marvelous things
happening out on that tabla rasa things
like the Black Rock Invitational golf
tournament where the greens were
beautifully painted with food coloring
and games of giant croquet using pickup
trucks as mallets yes the Black Rock
Desert had a reputation as a place to
make bold statements and so we arrived
Labor Day weekend in 1990 suddenly the
barrier to entry is high you had to
expend some effort to be there the
distance from San Francisco and the
difficulty of surviving in a harsh
environment with attendance down to
about 80 diehard people our little
Caravan pulled off the pavement at the
edge of the Black Rock Desert where I
took a stick and I drew a line on the
ground and I said on the other side of
this line everything will be different
then we all stepped across that line
together we brought with us Larry's
Burning Man the cacophony principles of
participation cost
absurdity leaving no trace of ourselves
and the rest each of Greek avenues
principles became coded into Burning Man
some of them became a written list of
ten principles some left unwritten still
taught to new participants by a
enculturation process
so we went to the desert and we built a
large wooden man there we were way out
on the playa it was so vast twisted by
mirages you couldn't see the camp until
you were nearly upon it we had much to
learn about the desert our attempt at
communal structure quickly collapsed as
we discovered that parachutes were
designed to catch the wind we spent much
of that first day lying under our cars
and trucks like lizards to escape the
brutal Sun but evenings were wonderful
John law
Chris Radcliffe and myself owned a neon
sign company called Central Services in
1990 John began the tradition of beyond
installations with this ground-level
artwork of white neon tubes here's John
law in 1990 he handled most of the
logistics involved in this trip we also
began a tradition of holding a cocktail
party before the burn in formal wear
very cacophony in those first years on
playa everyone pulled our rope to raise
the man Dave Warren lit the man that
year by breathing fire onto it by the
end of the three-day weekend it was
clear that we would be back again we
were already thinking waves to make it
better here's the next event listing in
the July 91 issue of rough draft some of
the highlights were when sailing red
bread-baking a bar and lounge and the
burn knight cocktail party we decided to
cover costs of the man transport in
porta potties with a $15.00 entrance fee
concerned with a harsh realities of the
desert we published the first survival
guide in 1991 neon was placed directly
on the man so it could be seen for long
distances at night during those early
years in the open desert
it acted as a beacon welcome home and
that year I drove the first art car to
Burning Man
beginning a trend that has grown to epic
proportions
1992 saw the birth and many long lasting
cultural traditions Marie Harvey once
said that the marks of civilization are
threefold that when you woke up in the
morning you wanted to toilet a cup of
coffee and a newspaper the first two
were already available to answer the
third need I published the first on-site
newspaper using a Mac 512k and a dot
matrix printer I quickly handed off the
Gazette to Stewart Mangrum who launched
the Burning Man communications
department 1992 also saw the it was the
first year that electronic music
appeared on the playa on Friday
turbo Ted played to no one but a cloud
of dust a couple of days later Goa Gil
played to a crowd of about 25 also in
1992 I started the Blackrock Rangers a
volunteer group of people with radios
who were charged with looking out for
the welfare of other participants
Blackrock is a large hostile desert
where participants often got lost
looking for camp getting lost out there
is literally deadly so I designed the
group to aim and emulate the legendary
Texas Rangers the frontier protectors of
a previous century we drive out on
search and rescue missions and bring
lost people back to camp there were only
six of us at first year but today the
Rangers number more than 800 the
beginning of serious sculpture on the
fly is generally considered to be this
piece by British artist serena Delahaye
also in 1992 is greg Schlesinger's flume
and Jim McCormack McCormick's Compass a
large cross made out of white tiles laid
out in onto the playa marking the
cardinal directions finally in 1992 we
were forced to renew our acquaintance
with government regulations back in 1990
we flew completely under the radar
no one knew we were out in the desert
1992 was the first year we had to fill
out a permit before
event.this is the campsite map that we
provided to the Bureau of Land
Management today we have an entire staff
working year-round to deal with our
federal landlords 1993 witnessed the
birth of the theme camp there had been
camps prior to 93 that had themes but
these were primarily someone's domicile
they were not promoted as attractions
for wandering participants to
investigate that innovation belongs to
Lisa Archer at Peter Doty who created
Christmas camp here Lisa's in the back
while Peter works the crowd out front in
fine cacophony tradition they never
broke character all weekend long lis
relentlessly played loud Christmas
carols and forced eggnog and fruitcake
on thirsty desert dwellers also that
year we were treated to an insane
exploding couple performance by Kim
Erick and Heidi Smith but there was some
other fireworks looming on the horizon
that year we experienced our first
scrape with extreme Black Rock weather
about 20 minutes after the man fell we
were hit by an epic wall of dust wind
lightning followed by rain it was
terrifying for many an apocalyptic and
oral legend here's John and Larry drying
out at the end of 93 we were so broke we
couldn't afford postage for the 1999 94
event announcement we thought we were
finished without that mailer there would
be no ticket sales next year and no
money to continue then a miracle
occurred during cleanup
someone found booklets of first-class
stamps strewn along the railroad tracks
hundreds of dollars worth that
mysterious jackpot carried us on to the
next burn
true story
so Burning Man continued and look at
this notice in 1993 it's still a pretty
intimate affair
we've reached maybe a thousand people
mostly friends and friends of friends
but see what's about to happen it's a
good thing we've already established a
strong culture because this is going to
test us to our limits it's 1994 look at
that miraculous postage here's the
mailer envelopes that I created which
carried the map and survival guide and
also acted as your admission ticket
we were now asking people to pay $30 to
attend the event but without any real
gate to enforce that it was pretty easy
to avoid and a lot of people came
wandering in from the local areas to see
what was going on who were all these
weirdos but blue hair and tattoos and
what were they doing out on the playa
burning a giant Idol they can clearly we
must be Satanist but we begin to see a
way to win them over a lot of
cacophonous had a wide libertarian
streak in them that's why we took so
well to Nevada we'd always had a flight
well-armed camp with many amusing
shooting events occuring against the
backdrop of the mountains after a couple
of years we thought we could connect
better with the locals if we invited
them to go shooting with this drive-by
shooting
[Music]
this is 350 79 will your head clean off
bråten area was absolutely nobody and
doing it for several years so this is a
totally safe thing but don't try this at
home so don't try this at home
no the neighbors won't like it everybody
is after barn I mean he is Barney is the
one that's gonna get zapped
[Music]
this is right by shooting ladies and
gentlemen
and it worked it began our ever
increasing rapport with the locals
they still figured we were Satanists but
we were Satanists with guns and they
could understand that another way way
that Larry devised to connect with the
locals was to describe everything is a
piece of work you don't talk about the
art or the meaning you describe the way
it's made in the process of building
soon you'd have them helping to build
stuff and there was a lot of stuff to
build in 94 we started making these
beautiful Lantern spires the year before
the lanterns had been placed on the
ground to form a processional to the man
after these blew away in that epic dust
arm Larry designed these fires which
made a moveable navigation markers Steve
mobile was our first Lamplighter
eventually we would need hundreds of
lamplighters for hundreds of spires
River the shark arrived from Texas in
1994 for many years had been an annual
art car parade in Houston Texas
following the lead of the 504 p.m. they
were starting to show up at Burning Man
before cellphones in broadband our first
direct communication to the outside
world was this pixelated photo being
from a yagi antenna on the playa to a
small Tower at Bruno's motel in Gerlach
and then uploaded to the Internet
through a 56k modem over a phone line
[Music]
hello world
the 1994 schedule of events there's no
time to rest now by 1994 we had hit our
stride we now numbered 2,000 people
looking out over the camp that year it
was magic I knew we were onto something
something big the world was coming in
1995 I started calling the camp Black
Rock City at 4,000 people we were now
the most populous place in Pershing
County we were beginning to attract more
on help
the tension from the government and I
felt we were due the respect that any
city would receive still struggling to
break even we now raise the admission
price to $35 per person
trying to look more serious I made
actual tickets for 95 see those
official-looking anti-counterfeit we met
features they're all fake 1995 we
budgeted $400 for a first Center camp
cafe run by Miss P Segal our cacophony
den mother the parachute a shade was
still a bad idea both the parachute and
the $400 proved inadequate but the cafe
went on to become the huge institution
that it is today
burning man's first web presence on the
well was advertised in the Black Rock
Gazette we offer a Burning Man as a
space station on the Internet the Black
Rock Rangers continue to evolve working
at the fire perimeter in 94 we had
trouble managing the crowd and I
realized I was wearing a confrontational
pirate flag on my chest
the Rangers needed an approach and an
image that was less confrontational and
more persuasive so I got together with
Bill Barker and Stuart Mangrum and we
came up with a design that was like the
man standing with the community circled
around it like an embrace it began to
change the nature of rangering in subtle
ways
here's anis torrid moment in 1995 the
first trash fence was tested at Burning
Man conceived by Larry breeds 75 yards
of orange netting was positioned
downwind to catch the trash this photo
shows the first piece of trash that was
caught by that fence
a fence that would later in compass the
entire city the calm before the storm
new people would love them our mission
is to reach new people but as word got
out about this thing in the desert the
population of newcomers began to
overwhelm our small staff and the
percentage of people who understood our
caretaking culture became ever lower
people were beginning to behave like
that mob on the beach in 1990 and we
began to get the Reno effect the
distance barrier for attendee Sereno was
much lower but they didn't know our
culture and as news of the events
started to spread through underground
independent media they began to arrive
in larger numbers just to crash the
party lack of a defensible perimeter
made that easy
many were surprisingly unfamiliar with
their desert back yard and often
survival a challenged but they weren't
alone the first blow in 96 was a death
of one of our own staff four days before
the event Michael Furey had been riding
his motorcycle drunk across the playa
playing chicken with a slow moving van
the resulting accident was gruesome few
people outside the staff knew about it
but we the organizers were devastated
didn't help that we had picked a theme
that year for the event and the theme
Dante's Inferno chaos was almost assured
as people tried to outdo each other with
fire explosions and diabolical
fire-breathing machine art hELCO was a
fictitional company that wanted to take
over Burning Man this is their corporate
headquarters which was incinerated in a
terrifying tower flame before the man
burned as I was rangering that night
some a couple of guys came up to me and
asked if they could burn their car
I said sure if you clean up afterwards
we burned everything that year amidst
all that chaos we had moved techno
ghetto
ka rave camp a full mile north of Center
camp to separate the large sound area
away from the general population now we
had an attractive nuisance outside of
town that required driving back and
forth all night long one night someone
ran over two tents seriously injuring
three people marred by these vehicle
accidents numerous injuries and one
death it was a difficult year
Burning Man had become a city and would
need to evolve in ways that would allow
management like a city disagreement
about the event between the event
Founders flared up was it time to
discontinue this experiment perspective
is a very personal point of view the
participants looking out and apparently
effortless city see everything that
looks easy but the organizers are down
on the ground the reality was much
harder intimately connected with radios
we organizers were effectively on the
scene of every crisis wreck and
emergency while the feelings from the
experience are very real being too close
to the center warps a person's overall
perspective I realized that the majority
of the participants had had a great and
wonderful time I wanted to keep doing
Burning Man for all of them we just
needed to adjust our course and find
ways to address the problems after the
96 event John law decided to stop doing
Burning Man
after the 96 event I decided that
writing the edge of chaos would be the
Rangers new motto we were still reeling
from the trauma and difficulties of 96
when Wired magazine put us on their
cover and notify the world that Burning
Man was a new American holiday
we were hitting the big time wow that
was a big six years now let's look back
at how that age felt we started with a
very high barrier to entry in a very
hostile but beautiful environment
initial enculturation was high within
our group but we had to educate and went
over the locals lack of a defensible
perimeter was mitigated for a while by
extraordinarily cultural development
like the birth of the Black Rock Rangers
the invention of theme camps the arrival
of art cars fascination with costuming
growth of the music scene the founding
of a cafe and newspaper the addition of
fire dancing and the beginning of
serious art on the playa in spite of all
that progress the shift from
word-of-mouth to alt media brought us a
huge jump in population and a near
descent into chaos how could we climb up
the third phase phase protectionism is
largely defined by burning man's
struggle for survival establishing
control of the city perimeter managing
cash flow public relations and
organizational development when we
expand the population curve outwards we
see that the bear the early years barely
registered due to the chaos of 1996 the
BLM refused our permit to use the Black
Rock Playa 97 so we moved over the hill
and onto private property in Hualapai
Valley a place called fly ranch
there was a small Playa next to it where
we could safely burn the man in 97 we
had a population of 10,000 our volunteer
construction team the Department of
Public Works began with a crew of
Midwestern circus roustabouts and bike
rodeo kids dubbed EPW it was organized
and managed by future board member will
Roger will brought his friend rod
Garrett a professional architect as the
city designer his plan had placed the
city inside the edge of the fly ranch
property next to the smaller BLM Playa
with design and construction teams now
closely linked the city infrastructure
developed rapidly this is also the point
at which Holly Dubois refined the
community services in the theme camp
placement departments a process that she
has started a couple of years before the
location in Hualapai Valley gay black
rock city its first natural protective
boundary there were only three roads in
it was our first taste of the advantages
of controlling access and we learned a
lot over the next four years next few
years controlling access to the event
was a major focus we finally got free
range driving under control and the
Black Rock Rangers no longer needed to
do search and rescue in the deep lieth
it allowed them to refocus on mediating
skills and general participant welfare
which is still their focus today the
ticket looked more professional than
ever and had an actual trackable serial
memory that year I implemented the idea
of dickin different ticket prices to
help smooth out cash flow accordingly we
sold early bird tickets for 50 and
tickets of the gate for 65 our first
jackrabbit speaks email newsletter was
sent out in 97 by Marian Goodell our
current CEO who greatly expanded our
communications department that year
today the J RS has hundreds of thousands
of subscribers a communication
department was also needed to handle the
influx of mainstream media in 97 we were
descended upon by CNN ABC Nightline NBC
Time The Washington Post a German
television crew and publications from
England France Japan and Brazil that
year the first Burning Man book was
published by Wired magazine
we were getting more organized more
communicative and for a while better
cash flow seemed like a great year but
being on private property
we had traded our federal landlords for
county supervision this was a mixed
blessing their book of festival
regulations required electric
streetlights payphones and marked
numbered parking spaces for all vehicles
when the county enforcement officer
arrived he realized how ridiculous that
was one good thing that emerged from it
was an improvement in our civic
structure Washoe County decided that we
needed street signs so emergency
services could find fires or injured
people in the crowded campsites
unfortunately they also determined we
must have there and needed unneeded fire
service and we must pay them over a
three hundred thousand dollars for
having that service on standby the
county sent the sheriff to impound all
of our receipts at the gate to make sure
the bill was paid
we ended up 1997 with zero money to pay
our bills and nothing to move forward
with in desperation Larry got on a straw
bale and made an impassioned pitch for
donations somehow we managed to get
enough to survive another year due the
success we had in controlling and
growing the event 97 the Bureau of Land
Management allowed us to return to the
Black Rock in 1998 wallop I had been
beautiful but the vastness and the
majesty of the Black Rock was our home
Black Rock city's population was now
15,000 and Burning Man volunteers
created department called Earth Gardens
to help the BLM manage the desert and
continuing the trend began two years
earlier the man was now raised off the
Playa surface on several courses of hay
bales straw bales for better visibility
but you could still go up and touch it
back on the Black Rock 498 there's more
room to plan a striking city ride Garret
evolved the city design he had started
at wallop high into a full half circle
there is now an art department placing
every
work on the open play on bringing rave
camp back into the fold the north side
of the city is designated louder while
the south side is quieter in 1998 our
ticketing process was turned over to
professionals after the tragedy of 96 I
added you voluntarily assumed the risk
of serious injury or death by attending
but I think that resulted in making the
event even more alluring to people 1998
is the first year their formal post burn
cleanup report is produced we organized
our first web team in 98 and they
created our first real website burning
man's following in the tech industry is
firmly established after we appeared on
the cover of Wired magazine in fact some
technology companies nearly shut down
during Burning Man here the first ever
Google Doodle in 98 was noticed to the
world that the kids were out playing
please leave a voicemail
[Music]
Marvel Comics published x-force vol 75
in March of 98 it proclaimed welcome to
the exploding colossal man shindig and
Halla balloon anyway our exposure
outside the playa continued to grow
Burning Man has now expanded to seven
days and you cannot see it all there are
twenty three thousand five hundred
participants and three hundred and
twenty theme camps in 1999 our Airport
is included on the city plan pilot Lisa
Schon would lead the growth of the
airport for the next 15 years
in 2009 the airport gained FAA approval
and was given the designation 88 in V
new key Hill Plaza open civic places
were added on the Esplanade then the
year 2000 brought us the final pieces of
the Civic puzzle now we would add some
features that nurtured as well as
protected our life within Black Rock
City participant responsibility is the
Leave No Trace ethic and it came to the
fore in 2000 our post-event clean
reports were becoming more elaborate and
we analyzed the trash left behind in
order to devise new participant cleanup
guidelines first we named our enemy move
which means matter out of place on the
playa that means nothing anything that
is not ten dust these are the guidelines
that were suggested by trace analysis
teaching these five things made a huge
difference for our developing playa
restoration crew in 2000 rod garrett
came up with a bold new design for the
center camp tent it's thirty four
thousand square feet of shade it was
designed as a large diaphragm a ring
pulled into compression by a membrane
which distributes loading from any point
working with the wind the slight peak in
the center deflects force and tends to
hold everything down this design was
modeled in a computer simulation and
tested there in a hundred and twenty
mile per hour winds without failure this
is the oculus inside this is the Civic
heart of the city and here it says here
is its Civic Sol two thousand marks the
first year of communal introspection at
Black Rock City three friends David best
Jack Haye and michael Heflin planned the
temple of the mind together but before
the event Michael died David and Jack
persevered dedicating the temple to
their lost friend it quickly became
clear that Black Rock City needed a
place to remember the lost there's been
a temple ever since the hush inside
stands in stark contrast to the rest of
the cities people covered inside and out
with messages memorials it's hard to
find a dry eye the temple is burned on
the last night of the event in almost
complete silence now comes one last
piece of the puzzle remember that short
strip of plastic fence in 95 when we
moved back to the Black Rock in 98
knowing the value of controlled access
we made that short strip into seven
miles of trash fence which formed a five
I did perimeter around the city the
Black Rock Desert is like an ocean and I
realize that a marine radar system would
enable us to keep an eye on that
perimeter in 2000 technology finally
sealed the boundary line between Black
Rock City and the outside world
here we're flicking it on for the first
time the parameters now monitored 24
hours a day during the event it detects
vehicles and individuals trying to sneak
in without a ticket by the 4th night of
operation we had caught so many
attempted gate Crashers it had paid for
itself the radar made a nice complement
to the night vision used by our
perimeter patrols perimeter remains my
favorite job on the playa there's
something about being out there on the
cool dark edge of all that creativity
which makes you want to protect it even
more and then it was burn night 2000 the
last burn of the 20th century closes
this inward-looking age of civic and
organizational growth it's the last time
we'd raise the man by pulling on a rope
together or the last time that we'd be
able to reach up and touch his rest
ruff skeleton and is it to memorialize
this laughs where the rite of passage
the do man wore this thorny crown of
fireworks and as a sunset on the third
edge he awaited his ritual demise
this was the age when Civic design
created civil behavior we developed a
community services department an art
department communication department and
the Department of Public Works and our
Rangers became mediators our center camp
cafe became our central gathering place
and the temple became our service civics
old and we gained a defensible perimeter
these things allowed us to weather a
financial disaster they rival the
mainstream media which steadily
increased our population this is the age
of outreach which is defined by an event
that's produced and run by what is
essentially a production company we're
so good at the event now we look outward
and the organization gives birth to new
endeavors also Burning Man art begins to
travel beyond the event the fourth age
begins at the yellow bar over the next
decade our population is going to double
but that's okay the cities dialed in we
can handle more people bringing more
fabulous stuff we want to reach
mainstream they deserve to have their
creativity Unleashed too with things in
Black Rock City running so smoothly the
event perks long on autopilot there are
a few major changes to none require much
explanation so always pass both of that
and focus on the outreach that we're
beginning to see back in 1998 a burner
named George pap returned home to Austin
Texas and started a small local event
modeled on Burning Man it was the first
regional burn and was quickly joined by
more affiliated burns nationwide in 2001
to help support them we fostered the
NASA regionals program with the silver
seed tour of America I drove this 30
year old spaceship looking RV which I
named silver seed after a Neil Young
song on a two-month trip across the US
with a mission to visit those new
regional groups and spread the Burning
Man ethos year round
the idea is expanding
and Burning Man art begins to get really
big really impressive and not flammable
meaning it could be repurposed
here's Michael Christians flock on playa
three months before it had previewed at
San Francisco City Hall for two weeks
we'll see more of this sort of thing in
the future acquiring a new ticket vendor
in 2002 The Burning Man ticket becomes a
work of art in its own right the theme
that year's the floating world then 2003
beyond belief admit one human Burning
Man is a testing ground for new ideas
the first hexayurt prototype was tested
at Burning Man 2003 by its inventor
Vinay group de May of installation board
and bi-directional filament tape the
hexayurt is a very effective disaster
relief shelter as well as a low-cost
insulated shelter option at Burning Man
in 2016 there were more than 2,500
hexayurts at Burning Man 2004 the vault
of heaven our regional network was
growing many more small affiliates had
sprung up around the world by 2004 the
founders of those events were faced with
explaining to a growing number of new
people what the heck Burning Man was and
why it mattered how do you how do we
explain who we are and what we do there
are no guidelines it had grown
organically from the seeds of cacophony
and we needed a quicker way to explain
it so Larry distill the essence of what
we'd been doing and what seemed to make
it unique into the 10 principles its
emergent not Dogma it's merely an
explanation
today a guides the entire regionals
network and gives us a framework for
analyzing our philosophy 2005 the theme
was psyche the nonprofit relief
organization burners Without Borders was
created that year when news of Hurricane
Katrina reached the event and spread
rapidly by word
nuf a huge relief what effort was
mounted which raised $35,000 at the end
of the event
scores of volunteers filled donated semi
trucks with food camping supplies tools
and equipment they left the playa and
headed for the Gulf Coast arriving in
New Orleans arriving in New Orleans
burners working in the face of brutal
adversity applied methods learned in the
desert building domes gifting supplies
fostering community and activating
personal networks to get heavy equipment
donated in a way that FEMA never could
dedicated crews adopted the moniker
burners Without Borders which truly
speaks to the future of Burning Man
taking the events principles off the
playa and out into the world hope and
fear of the futures the theme in 2006
population 40,000 the first matter out
of place map is published to visually
show the effectiveness of participants
cleanup efforts in their camping areas
the annual unveiling of the mood map has
become a big deal with people anxiously
awaiting news of how well their camp and
their neighbors can't measure it up peer
pressure is a wonderful thing these days
the map is much more Green speaking of
green Green Man was the theme for 2007
we don't pretend to be green per se we
can't our mission is elsewhere
and because making and burning artists
pretty toxin toxic and getting there is
resource intensive this theme rubs some
people the wrong way but we wanted to
discuss the concept anyway a tent like
pavilion under the man demonstrated many
sustainability projects and the pavilion
was powered by a large solar array a
burner brought this electric car
prototype for display at the pavilion
this might look familiar to some of you
Black Rock city's yellow bike program
was launched in 2007 a thousand bikes
were donated to Burning Man by one
individual to be used for our community
bike program we painted them green
because green man was our theme that
year I
outside of Burning Man people are more
familiar with the yellow bike program
run by a lot of cities like Amsterdam so
in a moment of data inspiration I had
the paint crew stencil this on each
green bike this ninety nine foot tall
wooden aldair worshiped by giant steel
figures was a powerful message about the
oil economy in a typical show of Burning
Man surrealism this Derrick was
incinerated by a thousand-foot column of
flame primed by 900 gallons of jet fuel
fed by 2,000 gallons of liquid propane
it was the largest fire ever produced at
Burning Man
[Applause]
Greenman concept if not indeed remember
I mentioned the solar array and the man
pavilion the solar panels left over from
the man base pavilion were used to
launch Blackrock solar the first 501c3
nonprofit solar company in the United
States
Blackrock so this first installation was
at the school and Gerlach the second
installation was at the Pyramid Lake
tribal reservation eventually they'd
installed so many free solar systems
along that highway that Nevada's
governor declared route 447 the Solar
Highway a lot of 2007 art gained
traction after the event the Steampunk
tree house was later installed in a
craft brewery in Milton Delaware big rig
jig a beautiful piece by artist Mike
Ross later made an appearance at
Coachella and at the 2015 Banksy art
installation in the UK 2008 the man
stood on a tower covered with flags from
all nations because the theme was the
American dream population fifty thousand
seven hundred and more artists going to
live beyond the event
here's Guardian of Eden by Kate rotten
bush it's now at the Nevada Museum of
Art it's the first Burning Man art
sculpture purchased by a museum for its
permanent collection in 2009 the man
stood on a tangle Bank a reference to
Charles Darwin's natural variation admit
one Homo Sapien to Burning Man 2009 and
on the legal front
longest four burners teamed up with a
Nevada chapter of the ACLU to protect
the rights of burners and to monitor law
enforcement sin creasing lis
questionable behavior on playa here's
the all-star team headed for the federal
courthouse in Reno the judge dismissed
most of the cases that day for
violations of constitutional rights
looks a little bit like Reservoir Dogs
doesn't it that year the gothic Reagan
rocket ship landed in San Francisco for
a while
metropolis life of cities art keeps
moving out into the world here's mark
Rowe Cochran's amazing bliss dance in
2010 which is now installed in Las Vegas
can Burning Man get much bigger yes but
not too much bigger and that fact brings
us to the close of this age so what did
this decade look like pretty great the
event has hit a stride were an odd but
efficient event production company we
roadtrip to reach isolated communities
of burners we pour resources into our
worldwide network of locally run
regional events creativity is at an
all-time high with artworks that begin
to travel the world burners spin-off
nonprofits for disaster relief and alt
energy we are really looking out at the
world now and wanting to help change it
what could go wrong the age of scarcity
in which Bernie man hits limits to
growth initiative at ahome we renew our
emphasis on regional events and we
physician to meet the future by becoming
a nonprofit in 2011 tickets the Burning
Man event sold out for the first time
ever the Black Rock Desert could easily
host a million people but getting there
and back is the bottleneck highway 447
is only one lane in each direction it's
a physical capacity limit that can't be
too
that's one of the reasons that the BLM
has always stipulated seventy thousand
person population cap in our permit to
rent the Burning Man site in 2011 we
reached that cap it was a rite of
passage for the entire organization
human psychology is strange the moment
something becomes scarce hoarding begins
even if you only needed one ticket you'd
buy two just in case even if you thought
Burning Man sounded stupid suddenly you
had to go now everyone wants in it's a
quest for the golden ticket seventy
thousand possible people but twice that
many requesting access what to do in an
attempt to be as fair as possible to
give old-timers and newcomers the rich
and the poor all the same chance to give
a ticket we try to take a sale by
loitering let an impartial computer
decide who goes to Burning Man when the
dust settled after the lottery many
burners crucial to our infrastructure
and theme camps were left without
tickets they were upset it turns out
that nobody really wanted a fare system
they just wanted to ticket many
experienced something like the intimate
betrayal you'd feel if your own mother
rejected you it nearly tore the
community apart we scramble to resolve
the problem creating a program to direct
tickets to department volunteers key
people creating themed camps art
installations and mutant vehicles that
curated ticket problems program still
exists and is still being refined about
35% of our tickets are now distributed
that way in a radical inclusion paradox
that adjusts the ratio of experience
versus new participants improving
inculturation
there's one other problem with scarcity
no matter how devoted you are to the
print Burning Man principle of
decommodification scarcity raises the
cost of access its supply and demand
scarcity favors those who can pay ticket
scalpers more for access it dis favors
the artists and creatives who invented
the culture paying whatever it takes to
get a ticket might destroy the fabric of
what you're seeking in the first place
wealthy people we love them too radical
inclusion right they have this much need
to explore the creativity as anyone else
but the arrival of wealthy newbies
creates requires yet more inculturation
many of the wealthy new arrivals are
used to buying all-inclusive vacation
packages they figured that's how you do
Burning Man - this gave rise to the
plug-and-play camps which we are now
working to mitigate exclusive isolated
camps were hired staff sort of every
whim are the antithesis of why we go to
the desert there's no personal challenge
and being pampered nope transformative
experience to their credit many
plug-and-play campers immediately get
that when they first arrive and they
return another year to throw themselves
into the full experience education will
remain our biggest challenge moving into
the future but I think we can win this
battle - our secret weapon of the future
will be our regional network which has
now more than 80 regions in 34 countries
doing events in places as diverse as
Spain South Africa China Korea Australia
and Argentina in fact the fastest
growing region seem to be in places that
have struggled with culture clash for
generations here is the third annual
midburn in Israel five days eight
thousand two hundred sixty four
participants 106 art installation 130
themed camps Palestinians and Israelis
camping together who would have thought
an Africa burn near Capetown staff out
in South Africa now in its eighth year
with 12,000 participants the latest
regional Burning Man culture is now
taking root in Russia and back in Nevada
burning man's recent purchase of our
1997 location sly ranch was made
possible with donations from dedicated
community members now we have a physical
pole star that our culture can revolve
around it all year and into the future
to guide that future to guide that
future we have transformed into a
non-profit we founders crimson Rose will
Roger
Harley Dubois Mary and Goodell myself
and Larry Harvey well someday have to
exit on that silver spaceship we're
passing the seed to the next generation
I believe the next generation will make
us proud
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I would like to point out that the
Nevada Museum of Art has just mounted an
incredible Burning Man history exhibit
called city of dust and it runs for six
months up until January 7th be sure and
catch it it's incredible
Reno Nevada yes it's not quite as far as
Burning Man
but you know it's thank you so much I
think there's parts of this talk that I
literally get chills in I mean starting
you know with that the moment in 96
which is kind of the first morning I
woke up at Burning Man was that morning
where I was the closest tent to the tent
that got hit yeah and and then but to
the end where you see that picture and
when I saw that picture of midburn at
Israel yeah it's just like sparks like
the 1996 moment all over again you
realize how things are going to evolve
in the future so thank you so much for
that and I'm also just curious as to
just a bit of your personal trajectory
as the Burning Man historian have you at
what point is you kind of feel as though
you were taking on this role or did it
just come on you began to take her over
gradually
we put together I want to thank my wife
dusty here she has spent many many weeks
helping assemble this talk and a couple
of others that I do doing research and
it's really great I want to think also
but I now I'm doing more and more talks
my role really is as a historian I have
collected saved pretty much everything
since the beginning so I've had this
huge historical archive stored in a
wooden attic in San Francisco you know
fires and says so I'm really relieved to
have it in the Nevada Museum of Art in
Reno that are taking really wonderful
care and they've mounted this incredible
exhibit and in 2018
the Burning Man exhibit is going to the
Smithsonian yes indeed and yeah it just
so happened that we were at when we were
at the Nevada Museum of Art was when
that collection was starting to come in
so a bill Fox who also spoke in the
series is helping with that I know I
want to open it up to other questions I
know that we'll have many and as I said
we'll have a short time but please do
raise your hand and raise your mic
because Michael will have already given
it to you Eddie
yes fascinating I so with the
acquisition of fly ranch recently does
that portend the beginning of the sixth
age of Burning Man and if so what will
that look like maybe so we're really
looking at Firefly ranch with what we
can do with it we want to use it to
promote and encourage the culture of
Burning Man and that encompasses
incredible range of possibilities right
now we have a team on site doing an
assessment that's going to take a long
time
we are cataloging every plant species
every animal and the geology the
hydrology and doing a very prolonged
study of what is their flying ranch is
interesting it's was a cattle ranch for
years even the fly geyser is a man-made
feature so there's nothing really
natural about that anymore but we want
to see what we can do with it it's an
incredibly beautiful place and it has a
tremendous amount of water on it so we
are researching that right now thank you
I've had a quick question but do raise
your hands and I'll get you the
microphone excellent so can you say
something about how the relationship
with Reno is today because obviously the
museum show is going up there but how
has that changed and how is yeah what's
the relationship within the Burning Man
and and the City of Reno Wow like even
in San Francisco you only spoke of
Burning Man and closeted you didn't tell
anybody you actually
and that was certainly the case in Reno
the meated blown all these crazy stories
about and so it was something that you
didn't really talk about it seen as
something bad and over time as we grew
and the art expanded and people actually
came out to see what was happening at
Burning Man we've had a tremendous
influence on what Bernie of what Reno is
to the point now we are such a part of
Reno there's more works of Burning Man
art in Reno than any other place in the
country the it's encouraged a
Renaissance of not only art but even
maker culture and I think that Burning
Man is going to influence even more than
that as we start to move into the realms
of technology and experimentation at
Burning Man and it's Reno's an exciting
place to be right now thank you over at
the bar so thank you there was a really
great narrative arc and and I'm you know
unveiling the way in which the ethos and
the operating principles of a structure
like this works I'm I just wanted to
notice that we're in a very interesting
era in terms of our civic society and
I'm curious what you think what would
you export from these this ethos of self
organization civic responsibilities etc
to other domains of existing civic sort
of you know experiences where much
needed reorganization
you know is desired what yes we are in
an interesting situation in our world in
our culture today I really think that
Burning Man has a lot to teach the world
in general what is happening is
particularly in this country we're
shifting away from a consumer society
and into an experience-based society and
there's no moral compass in that area
yet and Burning Man is teaching people
ways to have a community together where
everyone gets along and shared resources
and I think Burning Man can teach the
world a lot it's a very interesting year
for the Moscow Regional burn to have its
first here yes
I'm also curious I mean the the number
of years that this was the last year of
Burning Man because of the you know the
crisis a death you know that the the
ticketing crisis money crises the what
do you think was the special sauce
within the organization that pushed
through I mean there's any number of
these things would have would have
stopped another type of event and was it
this was it a particular mix of people
or was it some other interaction because
of all Burning Man is such a powerful
idea that it has its own momentum and
those of us who were there in the early
days we had the Burning Man experience
and the experience gave us what we
needed to prevail
thank you front so it sounds like
world's fair it sounds like you could be
doing instead of Industrial World's Fair
you could be doing a peaceful
transformation will
and and then you have all the spin-offs
it's there like the Maker Faire and all
the maker moves around the world you're
doing that too
and that could be cooperative that could
be a matter of using it as a forum to
show what you can do to survive
sustainably what you can do to work
together and cooperate I mean just all
that stuff becomes a theme that repeats
itself it gets expanded and exported and
made and I think that a lot of young
kids would really be fascinated with
that if they got to have the ideas and
the visions and some things to play with
that's a great idea and I'm looking
forward to you come out coming out and
getting it started
wonderful thank you indeed the early
principle of if you have the idea now
it's your job to attempt it poorly right
I think my favorite definition of
Burning Man from early on was great
ideas executed poorly exactly do we have
another question The Onion's eventually
hate you further so I'm really curious
like you know have you guys started
formulating a way to really try to
distill the embodiment of it beyond the
ten tenants and everything Oh distill
the embody and first of all at first you
can't really describe Burning Man
unless you've you have to experience it
to know what it is and I've been
thinking a lot about what is it exactly
the changes people a lot people's lives
and I think that's going to be the next
talk nice
I'm also curious
as a nonprofit administrator coming up
on the same age of an organization as
you there was you know there's a very
interesting transition that I think
you're getting close to as well as long
now and then there was also this
transition that happened many years ago
from a volunteer organization to a paid
organization which I can only imagine I
mean there's so much kind of volunteer
work that went in ahead of time to
create this thing and then all of a
sudden it shifts and then there's
profession you know it like now it's a
few people's profession but it still
needs you know massive amounts of
volunteer labor and I'm wondering how
that discussion went and then how what
are the thoughts in the going forward
part that you mentioned towards the end
yeah the the growth the evolution of
Burning Man has been a zigzag path and
it's been a learning curve and there
were some very difficult times certainly
in the early days when we suddenly found
ourselves spending months working on it
and hauling stuff out of the desert and
we say Josh I can't make the rent this
month and we first realized we had to
start paying ourselves and working
figuring out a financial system that
would begin to carry us through we began
as an LLC which was technically
for-profit but we of course were not
for-profit even then because we believed
in the vision of what we were doing and
eventually we realized we're starting to
get older and grayer and we need some
mechanism for this to carry beyond or a
lifetime and so we explored nonprofit
models and we found a very brilliant
attorney here locally Brook Oliver who
helped us Shepherd us through that
process
so yes it's a series of steps that you
go through thank you question-there
thank you so much for giving the stock
my question is around communication and
going into the future it seems like
Bernie man's gonna face
serious scaling issues but which you've
already begun to address especially
through the the regional groups when you
start at Burning Man the way that you
communicated with your group the
cacophony Society was very different
than the way that people communicate
today and sort of there's a surplus of
communication tools and also information
how do you view this communication
challenge in light of the event and what
kind of strategies solutions do you see
on the horizon in terms of the
communication challenge well you you
almost needed to identify what you mean
by those communication challenges I have
been keenly interested in communication
that the first thing I learned and when
I started the Blackrock Ranger since we
were on this vast place and we got
radios so we communicate way out there
so the Rangers had radios and they could
communicate with each other and go to
one place together we learned the
terrain and where things were at and
that was a first big step in
communication and now we're up to
several thousand radios and hundreds of
frequencies to operate the event and
that's just radio communications but
there was an interesting point I think
was about 1998 where I was out on the
playa and I was working with the Rangers
we were doing all this stuff and there's
fire and explosion and the sheriff was
out there standing by beside me and he
sees nothing but chaos and he was
freaked out but I knew what every fire
was I had Rangers at every place I knew
what was going on on the whole landscape
so communications is very important then
as the internet grew the comedy society
rivers I started you mail something out
and a month later you'd you you know you
would see who actually showed up at your
event it was it's like a flash mob in
slow motion
but there is an appoint in which the
internet really expanded and suddenly
all these images from Burning Man
flooded millions of images over the next
few years and all of a sudden people
began to take notice and people could
see oh this incredible artists amazing
things going out here that was the next
step in communication and then I
remember not very long ago when picked
up myself oh my god there's a cell
signal out here and a lot of people are
kind of ambivalent about the idea
because it kind of takes away from be
here now and at the same time it adds
another layer on top of things one of
the first flash mob cacophony events
that happened on the playa was because
we had phones and we used them to tweet
about an event that's happening at
midnight we're gonna sneak in and take
over this artwork and so at midnight I
show up there cuz I had heard about it
and I crawl into this place and inside
is a complete bar casino with a
nightclub act and it was strictly
guerrilla and this is the kind of pop-up
thing that can happen the what's really
interesting and will be interesting if
the future is the Augmented technology I
could foresee a time when you could be
walking on the playa and you'd probably
have your sunglasses or something and
there would be somebody else there but
they're not really there they're sitting
at a computer room somewhere in
Australia and they've got everything you
can have a conversation with it that's
what the future could be we can't go
back to those crazy wild days where we
ran around like naked savages but it was
glorious
[Applause]
but you remind me of an early experience
that I had I did a camp called
Antarctica which was refrigerated
semi-trailer so we did a dance party
during the day and we'd run it at 40
degrees and at one point we worked with
John Gilmore and Brewster Kahle to bring
a tachyon dish I think it was 98 or 99
we brought a real internet connection I
don't know it was the first one or not
but it was certainly the first one I
knew of and and we were doing a live
video chat in that Antarctica Jim
McMurdo Station and I sat this woman
down who's topless in front of the
screen and she's like she's like who am
I talking to hims like it's it's another
Antarctica the other Antarctica so she's
talking and it like eventually she
realizes it wasn't just a camp across
the way it was actually Antarctica take
her out and the guys who were wintering
over in McMurdo were pretty happy too
but that that kind of just amazing
connection it was both a good and a bad
thing and then a bunch of people in our
camp got emailed if all kinds of
tragedies in the real world and I
realized I never wanted a connection at
Burning Man again but I'm also curious
with this communication a million
stories in the Black Rock Desert and
that's one of them yes yeah I get to
tell my playa stories since I have the
mic the the enculturation and the
process that the that the Black Rock
Rangers have gone through what what
level of training do they get now and
how is that kind of I wrote the first
Black Rock Ranger manual in 95
the Rangers first of all they have to
have gone to Burning Man for a couple of
years to know what it's about that's the
first thing then they go through a
training program which is now happening
in many places around the country where
they're taught all about the the Rangers
and how to use techniques and strategies
for mediation with people and once they
arrive on site after
had that training they go through what's
known as a mentorship test and they go
out as Rangers in this city with two
seasoned mentors and it's like a test
and you passed so you failed and anyone
who wants to be a cop fails
automatically so we go to a testing
process to choose our Rangers that's
very cool
question on the stairs and you you
mentioned the turnkey camps and how
you're doing something to the
organization's doing something to
mitigate those camps now and why don't
you could speak more to exactly what
you're doing there and kind of how you
steer a ship that's so large looking at
the community moving it to the future
one way first of all we're encouraged
them to be interactive so we're only
given placement to camps if they can
show or demonstrate or have a plan where
they're going to interact on there their
boundary their placement so we're they
also have to have a plan for cleanup for
protecting the environment and usually
they have to have a person designated as
a liaison to work with us and work with
our team so we're going through a
process where we're finding solutions to
that issue thank you so Bernie man that
was described as an arts festival at
times and obviously you guys have
enabled lots of of arts but it's a lot
more than that as well but I wonder what
your thoughts are on there are a lot of
organizations that have wide impacts
around the world I don't know if anyone
that does has art at its center in the
way that Burning Man does and I wonder
about your thoughts of having art and
sort of the the engine in the center of
that how that differs from and the way
that that's led to the type of outreach
the type of impact that the Burning Man
has had Burning Man has already had a
tremendous impact on the art world first
the idea that anyone can do art and the
other idea that art doesn't have to be
locked into some stuff a gallery could
be out in the open
and heart can be interacted with and
that's so important so we've we've
already changed the face of art question
in the front and I don't think we've had
a single woman ask a question so I'm
gonna challenge we have one we did oh
sorry off our our own staff yes we've
had one woman out of all the questions
so I would challenge more female
questions I missed your grand juries how
rules get arrived at like the rule of no
dogs or the managing of people taking
photographs of naked burners and then
broadcasting them to the world and that
got finesse how do those you might
explain how that got finesse but how do
those rule decisions get arrived at well
we first of all it comes up as a problem
and somebody maybe not everybody but an
individual or a camp or a group of
people or some staff member has an issue
with something and we take a look at
that we first off it starts out in the
department the area that they're in and
then it gets filtered up to other sub
departments and we have its if burgum
has become very bureaucratic now it's
Brighton but it's still a much broader
institution than you would imagine and
[Music]
the leaders managers sit down and go
through long discussion sessions and try
to come up with an agreement
of what exactly is the issue and how we
can tackle it to solve the problem so
we've created rules by and large but
still Burning Man is the freest most
rule free place that exists there's so
many rules that have evolved or come
about in our society a lot of them are
just moral rules because somebody
believes some way and you shouldn't do
that
in the early days we ran up against the
moral code of many of the local
surrounding populations and even though
we were across the mountain in four
hours away they didn't want us doing
this or that because they didn't do it
in their town so I think really that
Black Rock City is the first really
global community that exists on the
planet not just the people who come
there from all over the globe but our
values that we have here that are shared
is truly global we long now
staff visited the site right after Burt
the fly ranch was purchased and for
around the time of early burn just a few
weeks several weeks before the burnin
last year and that there was probably
5,000 people on the playa at that time
which blew me away that the level of
organization that was happening in the
pot you know the population of the city
was already you know many percentage
points in it was weeks before and all
they were doing was building art and
infrastructure which I think people
rarely appreciate the the scale that
that's happening long before the gates
open I wonder if you say anything about
that evolution yeah ramping up to build
the city is really an interesting
process especially with Burning Man
having different areas of responsibility
that people are involved with we've
learned it's very important to have
volunteers and staff members have a very
strong vested interest in their area of
what they're doing and take pride in it
the Rangers and DPW have a tremendous
esprit de corps and what you want to do
is instill that and it's it's more value
than getting paid so what we've done is
instilled a sense of a pride and
ownership in what people are involved
with and then we have a system where it
organically grows where it's not
directed per se but they're given the
outline of what needs to be done and
they're able to grow their staff in an
organic manner very rapidly and it's
it's amazing building a city for 70,000
people within a couple of weeks a couple
more questions have other organizations
or individuals approached you to say
based on what you've learned how can we
have a more connective culture how can
we scale something in a positive way so
I hear two questions one about scaling
and one about connecting Burning Man is
a participant created content and there
are some organizations that are doing
very well with that tech companies
communication is another aspect of that
and it's an area that we need to explore
and more and more communication of our
culture and how do you spread it and
expand it and that scenario we're
looking into it
how to get my insights and make that
happen well sounds like we need to do
some research here question at the bar
Oh
eventually some academic in on this and
milk it for a hundred doctoral
dissertations on the dynamics of the
evolution of there's at least been a few
there's already been many many
dissertations and they're on the
internet and some of them are really
interesting so you should definitely
look those up there's there's a
dissertations about organization
dissertations about technology Burning
Man
there's there's a lot out there many see
Selden's and their planners to Burning
Man I mean that's moving on for a long
time right there's a group called
burning nerds which actually are tuned
in all of that
sorry it was there more questions last
question that's my Melissa having gone
29 times I'm curious what was the last
thing that most recently delighted you
surprisingly delighted you on the playa
firstly Wow
you know I'm always there's always
something new and delightful and
everybody finds something
what delighted me I don't know you know
I'm a jaded burner okay it takes a lot I
have seen things you wouldn't believe
and I believe in things you can't see
and I know things thank you thank you so
much
[Applause]
[Music]